what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation join once again by Roxy
Strayer who I demand you follow her on
social media she is always instagramming
and always twittering and she deserves
more followers Roxy how are you I'm very
entertaining I'm very proper and I'm
here for a good time with this descent
into madness can you stand for a second
no I gotta stand you gotta stand here
too short there you go yeah that's
better
yeah I'm so small we have to adjust it a
little guys what are we watching today
Roxanna said you said the thing to send
an event it's already Madness I was
setting you up I appreciate it wasn't
listening properly I was thinking about
the chair thank you for being here I
feel like you've been a wonderful
addition to the channel I'm obsessed
with it here I'm so so happy to have you
here each and every time leave a like on
this video leave a like yeah there's
some other horror movies I want Roxy to
watch it I feel like she'd really it joy
that I've already seen so my pair over
Tara for a very specific franchise okay
you told me this wasn't a horror movie
you said it was a comedy so I'm really
ready
I ruined it dang it ah crap I don't know
why I believed Greg when he told me it
was a comedy
I wanted to throw you off this intro is
all over the place Fuller Direction
watched along where you seek over their
own copy the scent uh available for
super sexy Rejects at a patreon page
cover a bunch of stuff exclusively over
there Rockstar are you ready to swing
into action my swinging monkey
I really am I think it's gonna be
playing monkeys the climbing monkey is
going to be swinging her chair back and
forth that I don't do well with the
horror movies sometimes so we'll see how
I am
thank you
okay so not in America cause mummy
this does not look fun what an opening I
know
I have a friend who does this for a
living really yeah what a terrifying
process yeah
[Music]
whoa
that's actually a pretty neat
introduction for a lead female character
a daredevil
let's go back to the car
I'll just help the girls what's going on
with them too
bye mummy mama mama
[Laughter]
she comes around she can help us plan
your birthday party this guy's got death
eyes are you okay you seem a bit distant
I'm fine
whoa
did was that dead husband or the little
girl okay it's definitely a husband how
far back does the polo holy [__] that
was shocking he thought he seemed
distant before yeah now he's
way up there hell of a comedy Greg it
gets funnier I've heard this
that is one of my biggest fears when I'm
behind a truck like me too
a ladder or anything yeah
just hate
is this a supernatural movie I don't
know
whoa
it was just the deprivation of her mind
it's a double meaning
it's clever descent yeah into madness
bro depression I think we got it we're
deep
you're right we don't have to do this
but I'm not going to be the one to tell
Juno she's a piece of work she came to
Scotland last year yeah and left pretty
quickly well I mean [__] happened I
don't make someone leave everything's
gonna be fine it's gonna be great
Rebecca said I can't wait to see you
once you got in sure she loves me and
talk to you like that after a year
it's gonna be better yeah who needs your
family
I am loving the way this is shot it's
got such a such an atmosphere to it I'm
definitely with you Sarah this is Holly
Juno's Protege bass jumping you should
try it Juno showed me a photo of when
you used to climb together oh no my bad
this classic picture what a unique set
of characters yeah that's really
different
love each day
to do some employees to see
don't bring the room down lady it's an
interesting way to introduce an ensemble
it kind of actually is reminding me of
the thing where I don't know anybody a
lot of their names or backstories
you don't know any of these actors right
Jesus that's so scary
laughs
not again
holy [__] is the only scare for like
every 10 minutes
whoa you never know Paul's just gonna
drive through her in any second
that was really normally when you enter
a nightmare sequence it's really
apparent yeah they did a great job at
misleading you there
the score is awesome too yeah it's
really capturing this dread intensity
give me five minutes five minutes
I love how she did a warm-up run when
they're already gonna do a crazy
adventure today
yeah but there's always that one person
on a trip that's like that
fascinating transition yeah
that's what you call it
a thing Holly
I hate that person on a trip right
ladies
hey give me a smile oh my God their last
photo
[Applause]
there's no sausage to be seen
yo this shot is Straight Up The Shining
have you seen The Shining yeah Straight
Up The Shining right here with the water
bottles just uh where the camera's
moving I don't know what you're talking
about the water bottle water cups what
I don't know here's Johnny right I don't
remember movies I don't know what I've
seen and I haven't signs
I figured out the same time too
[Music]
going the right way
I've never been lost in my life
marvelous do you like Juno right now or
you dislike her she's all right I think
they're all fairly likable yeah early
prediction that Juno was born was
sleeping with uh his husband yeah
probably that's what those shots seem to
allude to and just her personality
nice parking
I love the cinematography yeah God uh
this lives up to the title of descent so
much it's just becoming this dark blue
that's just overshadowing the frame I
love it running late
a great grip on sound design too yeah
everything like every sound punches I
want to buy a BMW now the river about
half
of my flat and stick to it rule number
two don't go wandering off you can get
dehydration this orientation
this is so clever they're setting up all
the terror to come while they're
painting us with this beautiful nature
scene and everything it's like pride and
positive
love it this is it you're having a laugh
I'm an English teacher not [__] Tomb
Raider
oh what a gorgeous shot yeah really good
with movies like this it makes you
wonder how did they get some of these
shots especially as we're going into the
cave it's like yeah did they shoot this
in an actual cave on location
[Applause]
honestly in order of following my lead
okay let's get a moment shows that she
does take this serious yeah only
redeeming moment for her character you
really don't like her
if she didn't sleep with him then I do
and my bad Juno
and that one's for all you men out there
God damn sound design man freaks me out
look how Batman
which way there's only one way out of
this chamber and that's down the pipe
it does a good job at capturing The
Wonder of a lot of these elements and
then switching to but here's why it's
also terrifying
oh yeah there's a big No-No for me this
is way too terrifying I would not do
this it takes a different breed of
person to be wanting to do this like
this is way too scary to figure I would
never do this I get being intrigued but
I I just couldn't
I wonder where they did shoot this it's
wild this reminds me of 47 meters down
I like how a lot of these shots look
like matte paintings like a like an old
school Hollywood movie
oh
I will I will kill you do you know
say that I'm really sorry I didn't stay
around longer
accident anyway
she's crying because she was sorry I'm
feeling a bit out of it it's probably
jet lag or something so I'm just going
to take a look around okay it's been a
year I'm sure she doesn't want to keep
talking about it what's up with her she
looks like she's seen a ghost or
something fine and that goes in there I
think what's up with her so what's up
with her girl's gonna go first I don't
know that for sure hence why it's a
movie I haven't seen
I found the next Passage
I would be scared if I yelled things
would just start kind of collapsing like
Aladdin rules or something
this is not how I imagined it from
reading the book that's why I don't
trust books careful just find the way
through are they finding like a gateway
to Hell what I'm trying to figure out
what's from the book where this is going
yeah I think they're all under different
premises right now like different
submissions I'm saying like you know
what I'm getting at yeah I feel like
they're like fighting like but you were
actual hell you think this is gonna be
Supernatural I don't know I have no idea
I don't think so I think they're just
gonna get stuck Underground
whoa cool shot really cool yeah
God they're claustrophobia so that sucks
so much are you not good with MRIS
I do them weekly
just to prove I'm not a [__] dress
word
she's the one who I said was gonna die
first right I think so
yeah yeah
gross
the way they laugh sadists
oh no
I can feel it coming in the air
yo she's like legit stuck Sarah are you
still behind me
you should be fine should be fine Greg
she's fine Greg guys it's Sarah I think
she might be stuck
ah what in a comfortable position
keep breathing
okay
hey okay okay
what are you so worried about Sarah look
at me okay okay breathe
what are you so worried about Sarah
you're fine are you her therapist listen
the worst thing that could have happened
to you has already happened okay and
you're still here
I love this girl yeah
I'm gonna move slowly that's it grab my
arm okay
I forgot the Rope back okay
oh my goodness okay
[Music]
oh my goodness
what is happening
if it was anyone else I'd be nervous but
Sarah's not gonna die she's a
protagonist so I could still feel her
emotions you soulless woman Roxy Solas
it's like 47 meters down on cage thing
pretty sure four centimeters down came
out after this so
that's how it's supposed to work except
I put in a flight plan for Borum caverns
and this isn't Borum Caverns is it Juno
we're in the wrong [__] cave
oh God Caverns was a tourist trap I
don't try and pin this shite on me this
is not caving this is an ego trip come
on Rebecca I didn't know this was gonna
happen you don't have enough oxygen to
fight about this where
a name it's a new system I wanted us all
to discover it no one's ever been down
here before
you know you couldn't get away fast
enough
we all lost something in that crash
she was sleeping with her man
how'd they shoot this I don't know it's
masterfully crafted though like they
really did an excellent job
I think you're right about Juno because
it seems like Juno and Sarah are both
grieving in their own ways yeah for sure
I have three camps I need at least three
more where's the other rope bag
where is it
we lost it when the cave collapsed
all right whoever does this is probably
a goner because right about that timer
we're gonna lose somebody
we didn't even like draw straws for this
job nah man
I just know who the best one is for the
job
Jesus
such
prowess I can't imagine
I think we're I think we're in trouble
come on come on
come on Rebecca
yeah yell at her to go quicker
oh there's one right there
you okay that is
scary you're gonna try to use it or what
oh my God
I don't know about that babe
[Music]
what a reveal that others have been here
that is so well done super well done
oh no
well done do you think everybody makes
it across us
yeah I'd say so yeah I think you're
crazy
[Music]
don't look down back keep going who's on
there right now Beth
Beth is a more likely name
it
I thought maybe your name
or maybe yours
oh no she's gonna be okay but this is
not gonna go well for her
we'll need everything we got
haul it in
oh yeah this Juno girl's in a lot of
pain
yeah yeah
she just like really wants to live close
to death
laughs
oh no is she gonna notice the one that
was already there too
I mean I might just assume they put it
there
they all must be ripped I know right
they all must do American Ninja Warrior
oh she must have [__] her hand rope
burn yeah
going on ouch
[Music]
you could like feel that this
equipment's at least 100 years old no
one uses stuff like this anymore besides
if anyone had been down here and made it
uh they would have named it already so
we're lucky they probably died we get an
opportunity
I hope one of them has a first aid kit
losing the Rope bag we lost Juno was
like that at first first
gets in the way of the risk is something
down here I can't believe they've all
made it this far
what Mesopotamia
do one of those purple light things
oh damn but the mountain the cave and
there's two entrances it means there's
another way out come on
that's why you do this for that end
result and then you get that high of
overcoming it I just feel like it's not
worth it
yeah
what was that did you see that yeah
is that an animal I just thought it was
water no I'm pretty sure that was a an
actual living thing come on come on
what are they trying to do that one
all right that's the reason to find Like
Oxygen air waves yeah
okay this is gonna be the first dead
person
oh yeah
oh
whoa whoa whoa
it's not daylight it's what
oh I was right yeah congratulations
oh is she alive
oh my God it's gonna be like a bone
sticking out or something gross isn't
there
definitely broke her back
[Music]
oh no I kind of don't want to see it
don't move oh there it is there's the
boat
can you imagine that Discovery if you
had a problem sticky
is she
I'm really upset with myself that
the baby
yeah
[Applause]
is that while the bone is protruding I
need to push it back in oh no
oh God
[Music]
there's a hundred percent something else
down here
[Music]
yeah it's the shark yeah
what is that
Is that real
[Laughter]
it was calling bro
look at me
there's nothing there
I think that would that had to have been
real right I don't know I think that was
real I saw a man are you sure yes and
it's not the first time I thought I saw
someone before but now I'm sure
you all have to get out of there I I'm
kind of upset with myself that I was
happy when I thought Holly died first no
no you're a sick human being you're a
perverted human being that was nice of
me sorry for smiling
are those bunnies yeah
that looks like Sarah
uh Sarah and Juno are there there's
multiple people two lights yeah yeah we
get out of here which way are you
confident it's dead animals
oh what the hell was that
whoa that just came out of nowhere
did it did it take one of them this is
like that movie that came out last year
with Mother downstairs
the Airbnb rental movie with the mother
oh yeah yeah yeah Barbarian that's what
that creature looked like coming out of
nowhere
oh my God
whoa
[Applause]
is that the girl
this is I don't know she did die first
yeah she did die first
[Applause]
nice way to go Juno is she getting in
slashes on him she just got one
[Applause]
girl
is it vampiring
nice work
no
oh this is bad bummer bro
why didn't she say any words though
devastated shock or something
no but you don't sneak up on somebody I
don't think that one's Juno's fault
kind of Juno's fall
just saying like she was in attack mode
I understand what happened yeah were you
watching yeah
it's got to be some metaphor
metaphor in coming I'm curious how I
feel about the goblins
I like it yeah I I do too but because
they're uncovering a creature it does
make it less grounded of a film which is
cool but different than what I was
thinking we were doing
[Music]
let's go over this cave and there's a
whole new kind of creature down here
what's your predictions on who makes it
out alive anybody I think just our one
main girl just Sarah not Juno I don't
think Juno's gonna make it we need a
reveal of what Juno did
that noise is
my precious
[Applause]
so they're auditory creatures
we can't see
some kind of humanoid thingy I don't
know what the hell they are oh there's
an arrow it's an arrow
you saw that yeah it's pointing that way
yeah I feel like that's the way they
should Escape
[Music]
even the music becomes like classic
monster music
smart
Becca God damn it stop yelling you dumb
[__]
now it's just about survival these
arrows it's just about survival now oh
no Greg oh no oh no oh no oh no what oh
no why are you saying oh no what's
happening it's just not good I can just
tell something's about to happen I don't
know shut up who are you doing
all right
you're scaring me I know
no you don't speak they don't no she's
getting it
why do some of these creatures who can't
see still have eyeballs my take is that
they've been down here for so long that
they lost their sight so they had to so
it adapt it by making up for having a
really hiding sense of hearing so you
think they were humans
that's my guess they're too humanoid
[Music]
I I wish I understood what she was even
trying to do oh
now again
[__] [__] [__]
ah
[Laughter]
climbing monkey
s
fight it
oh nice was that Juno
damn Cheetos Rising
you want Juno in your corner for this
stuff oh totally thousand percent yeah
they're totally blind and judging from
what we've seen I'd say they use sound
to hunt with
like a bat and bat
I found those more kicks
yeah because you're a screwinger man
what if they don't really say anything
I'm positive a woman knows this is what
happened let me ask you this if she was
with her man but gets her out of here
alive is the even Steven no okay this is
all Juno's fault it's happening
what
no way you're surviving
she's gonna tell her Juno did it right
oh damn
how is she still alive
she's noticing the necklace yeah yeah
Juno do this
love each day that's what her husband
used to say remember at the beginning of
the movie she said that I know yeah
because she was right
please kill her come on yeah but it's
hard to do don't ask me
but it is hard
killer oh that would be hard hard to do
if I had like a blade
okay
how did an action scene go down so who
did just who was just there
I actually have no idea what just took
place oh yeah I don't know what happened
it was too dark
[Music]
oh cool what I think it's the cover that
we're gonna see
oh yeah it is red
oh yeah is that how they get out to the
world is the exit that way
and you see the cover is this what the
oh
you must survive to confront Judo
[Music]
[Applause]
reach it reach it reach it reach her
reach it
every step step
[Music]
puncture
oh it's definitely she's that's blood
that is a that is a big pile of blood
oh look how smart she is oh my God
that's crazy
but what does that think it is on
where's the video camera
to prove to the world
boom
you don't think the video camera matters
it's the most important thing the whole
thing
they're vibing if you don't get this on
tick tock
you must survive to confront Juno
why would you yell they're right there
they were right there
[Music]
the Two Sisters the big ones Gotta Die
no the one who's like just completely
petrified the entire time
[Applause]
nope nope she she don't give a [__]
back please baby listen to me
consequences
foreign
they're gonna have to climb across her
body to get across
[Applause]
what just happened
uh oh she's jumped
just give her a titty twister no craft
an item out of him
[Laughter]
we don't have that much time left in the
movie Greg what's gonna happen here I
don't know I wonder if Sarah's gonna
kill Juno maybe she just doesn't save
her or maybe they both get out alive and
become lovers
saved her
[Applause]
what about Beth
make it
you saw a day
[Laughter]
come on maybe quiet honey
oh no
oh [__]
I can't even hey
holy crap
[Music]
oh
the amount of infectious diseases they
would all have
this is it
we know what you did why would you wear
it handicapper
[Music]
to get out no nope nope they could just
use her
[Music]
how many are there so many
is there daylight that's gotta be actual
daylight
but then why with bones
uh
is this the cover
massive spoiler of a cover
the Ascension
don't pull her back down get out get out
she have the keys to the car
for her
is one of the creatures in there
just camped out
that would really suck if there's
something in the back suit she gonna get
like charged with murder of all of her
friends
[Music]
don't pull over keep going keep going
don't get out of the car
now this movie it would suck if she died
I would be I don't think she's going to
but I want to see like what what are we
on her for there's something else that
has to happen then
it's a truck you found it
Fair surprises took her that long
oh
weird ending moment there Wicked
Wicked
I don't know any of these people do you
look they're called Crawlers
oh good name
Craig Conway a scar they named that
crawler scar sweet just like after Lion
King their favorite movie
well Roxy what did you think so good I
mean they just did an excellent job with
that
because okay the the big reveal
obviously is that this is a monster
movie which I feel like you might have
gotten more sensitive than I had going
into this because you had seen that
cover with her covered in blood so maybe
were you thinking I mean no when they
arrived they had the the thingy they had
the dead animals and stuff so it just
seemed like they were hinting that
there'd be something I was thinking
something as in like Rams
like a real live creature down there oh
you thought they're
you thought there would be like a more
realistic animal because we saw the
painting on the wall with the the reason
that's why I said ran it was like yeah
okay so I was thinking it was more like
maybe a mountain lion kind of thing or
some I don't know what creature but
Panda yeah something crazy yeah under
there I wasn't thinking it was gonna be
a humanoid of sorts right
um but that was a interesting choice and
then like once I could kind of wrap my
head around the choice and really
embrace it and then there were so many
of them it was a whole different Society
down there I was like this is dope
yeah I thought that was what made it
clever was because they they were kind
of like planting Little Seeds throughout
like they had the hand on the wall at
the beginning yeah that everyone seemed
to ignore I'm sure it's nothing it's
just fresh blood right here on the wall
and there's something just about its
mood and tone
that seemed to hint at it have you seen
the Netflix movie the ritual no this is
the most that it reminded me out of all
the movies we kept listing this is the
one I thought of the most but I when did
this come out let's look that up yeah
that's very serious when you watch a
movie with Roxy it becomes a whole
Google session is what this is why is it
what do you mean you're always like
what's the 2007 it's 2007. well why is
it listing Rosaria Dawson
um oh that is the movie Descent
you're right
okay that is the wrong movie okay
[Laughter]
okay something's awesome that's why
where's The Descent how come it's not
popping up here maybe try IMDb
it's the international movie database
that's what it is something happens when
you are like boxing unless they've got
the title on the whole time 2005. wow
2005 yeah okay
um
something else you want to look up no
there's just this is much earlier than a
lot of the movies that borrow from it
clearly and it's still yeah a lot of
movies borrow from it it still feels
it feels like it still could have come
out like this year yeah yeah well it was
interesting the lack of technology in
this made me wonder about the year
because we don't really see I don't I
don't remember seeing anybody on their
cell phone or whatever it is no but you
wouldn't because it's cave diving so
yeah it does it does feel like a totally
Timeless movie
yeah it's really clever I was so
impressed with that the way it just kept
going I haven't quite seen
quite seen a horror movie like this in a
while I've seen other movies that kind
of feel a little bit because it's
another horror movie about like grief
and then going on an adventure and
overcoming and changing as you go but I
love the parallel journey of the the
cheater and the woman who lost her
husband and kid and how they're both on
these like two grieving Journeys
together except we don't like uh Juno
you're not aware I mean she's not making
it um public information for people I
bet some people watch this movie and
don't even interpret it that way
well that is what's happening right
that's why Juno's always like we got a
little fear and I gotta like make up
with Sarah and I gotta do it you know no
I'm saying don't even interpret like who
knows what her relationship with the
husband was like you know we have no
idea was she in love with him was she
sleeping with him
oh
um I mean she was clearly in love with
him yeah because that's but she couldn't
it was it the guilt that was you know I
think there could have been so many
different versions of it was it a
full-blown affair with an infatuation
was it both side it was it one-sided we
don't know and they don't focus on it
because it's not fully the points when
when you have wronged somebody so deeply
there's no time you never able to make
it right because of what happens and
you're also never able to come clean
about it this is what happens to you
that's what I mean that's why that's why
I like Juno's the character of Juno even
though yeah like awful human being like
but I like the character of of her
because
it makes sense why she would be acting
out in such a different way because she
can't talk to anyone right a therapist
would have been good but outside of a
therapist she she can't confide in any
of her friends and then she's trying to
make amends with someone but she can't
confide she can't be like well I loved
him too yeah and they never even used
they never even bring it to words right
it's kind of crazy it's clever yeah very
really really good really really solid I
think that this movie it took every inch
that it could
like for being what it was which is a
movie that has no A-list celebrities or
b-list celeb people that you've ever
heard of and it's almost all takes place
in a cave it gave us everything
perfectly yeah the user environment well
it was like wet icky harsh uncomfortable
the sounds are like they they know how
to thrust in the perspective and
um
I just love a good title so I kept
bringing it up because it is it is such
a great title for this uh because it's
it it plays on every ass it's it commits
to it so much to the T on every aspect
of the psychology and the physicality of
everything and then how it leads
ultimately to her Ascension I think that
is so great so yeah I was really
impressed with the title and the way it
was shot was so excellent because they
know how to thrust you into everyone's
povs and we were kind of comparing it to
the thing in the beginning
um which is a movie I watched yes that
is a movie you did watch
of air you up again sometime in like you
know 2027 so it's not that far away
um yeah but I like the Dynamics here
more yeah I did too we got to know a
little bit more about the characters
here and and like you said the Dynamics
knowing like the sisters versus Protege
versus Frenemies or whatever it was I I
really did enjoy that I thought that
they did a great job with this Ensemble
not diving too much into their
backstories but enough that when
somebody died I was like that's a bummer
yeah oh except for when I was excited
about being right about the first day
sure sure
you had a great time yeah because I was
able to predict some things I mean I I
pretty early on clocked I I think that I
was like oh is it that girl's family and
then it wasn't her family and I was like
oh the way they shot it clearly there's
something here and then it was pretty
soon that I realized what was going on
between them but it didn't take away
from the movie at all it was like okay
this isn't about that this is a survival
movie I'm curious looking at this
there's a The Descent Part Two I'm sure
it's a straight to DVD monstrosity
because or no I don't know actually
that's my dad okay let's find out 2009
let's look up if it was
was the scent I'm just going to Google
it was the different director
oh that makes me less confident yeah was
The Descent
part two
theatrical release
let's see it seems like in the UK it was
but not in cinemas it was uh
not it was straight to DVD and I had a
51 on Rotten Tomatoes so yeah okay well
that's not too bad for a horror sequel
honestly uh that's like well all things
considered that's not bad for uh for a
horror sequel to be I wonder oh so she
she revisits the caves that's
interesting oh cool yeah yeah
we saw that same I mean you can't have
that same surprise and and also
um
the because you said like it is a
survival story and I love it because the
whole time it's just stripping them down
to their their Bare Bones their bare
Souls by the very end of it their most
vulnerable and you see what they succumb
to when it comes to survival and because
they do such a great job on capturing
the intensity and the horror when it's
just a cave Expedition movie yeah
nothing to do with monsters totally you
know and that is in and of itself is
already scary enough as it is and you're
watching them devolve and so and then by
the time you get to the finale like I
actually thought the monsters help to
propel what they were doing with the
characters already and I think that's
why I was able to get on board because
it is a little jarring that kind of fits
with the reality of the situation
because you wouldn't see that coming in
real life so I think in some aspects it
I like how it kind of comes semi-left
field like there's some there's some
minor hints that there's another
creature down here right that's why I I
didn't it's not like I didn't think
anything was down there I knew something
was down there but if you're like me
watching this and you feel like it's a
very grounded thing I just thought it
was going to be an animal of some kind
yeah I I'm with you though that when it
does kind of come out of left field it
doesn't feel like what were they doing
with that that was a weird Choice it
just feels like oh okay I see I see why
you guys did that makes perfect sense I
the way that it was shot 99 of the time
really worked for me the one percent
where I didn't know what was happening
sometimes I do wonder if that was a
financial thing where sometimes they
just didn't have it enough fun to show
me what was going on there's that one
moment where after Sarah has said
goodbye to the girl with the necklace
who's dying and then all of a sudden
there's the oh yeah whatever and I was
like until this moment I don't know
whether they heard something or that was
a different scene that we cut to or what
so it was just a cut there was maybe two
or three of those times where I was
truly unclear about what happened yeah
it doesn't make me not understand the
whole movie but there was a couple times
where I was like if you could have just
been a little more uh coherent with that
then that would have been cooler in
those moments right true true because I
love how obscured everything was and I
love how
um unsettling and disorienting
everything was that's true that's kind
of the point but then at times I was
like
[Music]
between the two of us four sets of eyes
where are they show them uh yeah but it
was definitely the disorienting part
that you said though it's supposed to be
disorienting so that's why the the
editing really does work for me most of
the time it was just those few nitpicky
moments where I was like huh I don't
know what I don't know how we did that
all right that's fine this is one of
those movies I would be curious to see
the making of on because these actors
all got in the
ugliness of it all like this looks like
a really uncomfortable thing to fill it
bums me out that this was came out in
2007 and I still don't know any of these
actresses because they were really good
yeah they were phenomenal that's the one
problem with horror is a lot of the time
you Horrors that one category where you
don't need a celebrity at the same time
it doesn't really make stars yeah yeah
but also the fact that I know that's
okay that's not for everyone who's gonna
clarify some people become actually
famous from horror movies I know but
it's UK horror too so who knows maybe
they're very big in the UK and we just
don't know them but the girl who played
Sarah and the girl who played Hulu
who played the app Hulu now streaming
because I do know I got her the whole
time I can remember her name two seconds
later I forgot those two girls are like
to me they were such stars and Sarah is
kind of like a low-key incredible final
girl
that's what's neat is the fact that I
was thinking that too because it's a
whole the whole cast is women yeah that
you might not immediately think final
girl because normally you associate that
one like there's men mixed into the
group yeah um but yeah she is straight
up that's what she is the Final Girl of
all the girls she's the final girl so I
this is uh a weird thing but I was do
you know I was a girl scout for 13 years
oh were you okay so until I was 18 which
is how old you're allowed to be when
you're a girl scout so did you petition
that did you fight were you like no they
don't want to keep going for another
five no but I would have kept going I
love Girl Scouts so I'm kind of like a a
wee bit of a nature not with some things
like I love to Camp I love the outdoors
um and my dad also used to rock climb
and I love
um no joke I did love rock climbing not
to this extent and I'm not like a
excellent I'm not a cave Diver by any
means but I was kind of in communities
that like to do this kind of thing and
this reminded me of the conversations in
the cabins in the woods and whatnot it
reminded me uh I felt like this was a
female writer which I don't think it
actually was which means they did a
great job because remind me of the
conversations that you have and it
didn't feel like what do women talk
about when they're doing outdoorsy
things it felt like really what people
are talking about and and how they're
conversing and that's why I love how
they didn't make that huge deal about
like you were cheating on me my husband
you whatever like this was very
realistic to me a lot of times when we
see men write these things it does get
very Petty and catty as opposed to this
which felt really realistic and grounded
even though we've got goblins
that is true I think Neil Marshall I
think the saint I think he wrote it too
I think gotta know Roxy that's why I
make you Google Greg has to Google this
to find out
um I think he wrote and directed it too
yeah
um yeah that's impressive really good he
did a really really good job with the
dialogue in this it was just that one
line that both you and I were like maybe
we could ask for help no come on you
know yeah you know yeah you know you're
not asking that thing
totally yeah maybe he knows a way out
okay but yes I I just kudos to him to
for understanding how to write these
characters that is a great point because
I didn't quite know the the kind of
people I was liking it to I once did
Tough Mudder and uh you did yeah I was a
nightmare I threw up nine times I hated
it but I want to do it again but you you
did it yeah I survived I did not know
exactly what it was that's amazing and
uh it was a I heard to say I do not
prepare for it but I did the whole thing
and it was really hard that's crazy and
and I got to do it with it was one of
those like influencerable it was like
the first influencer thing I've ever
done
it's such an influence it was such an
influence yeah but this was this was
when Studios started working with
influencers so they're like let me hire
you for something which is we're gonna
like film you do some activity needless
to say I was not mentally prepared or
physically at all for what Tough Mudder
was but they put stupid YouTube talking
about movie trailers guy with American
Ninja Warriors and people who had
actually done Tough Mudder before and
there were these women there's like one
woman who was part of our group who had
done like a 19-hour tough mudder before
I'm like that is gnarly and then so yeah
seeing like and I met quite a few of
them oh these conversations kind of
reminded you yeah yeah I was like oh
yeah these like Thrill Seekers athletes
um who like love to get in the muck and
really do these kind of crazy things so
yeah while it wasn't like you know cave
diving but you those athletic Thrill
Seekers uh yeah it reminded me of that
so there was this authenticity that you
could latch on to I wonder if there was
like a lot of improv allowed to yeah
possibly it did feel it did feel that
way just in some of their responses to
each other
um I loved it I I loved it a lot that
that's gonna stick with me yeah it was
really really solid perfect length to
the score was awesome oh yeah the score
yeah just some really smart choices
I think we've broke it down I think
we've got everything we need out of them
we took the Descent to the film yeah
I remember when you started laughing at
me
because it's like a [__] like the
70th time yeah so the thing about it
yeah
couldn't get over it it's a really
really good title it's too good if I'm
with you I'm definitely with you it's
not you weren't wrong any of the times
it was just cracking me up how often you
were thinking about it it's normally
such a pretentious thing to say like the
title itself can somebody can be so
pretentious and heroes like oh they're
doing it they're they're so committed to
it that I was like there is no there's
no other title that would that would be
perfectly encapsulated
do you have a favorite movie title
uh
you'll have to think about for next time
A lot of times it's comedies that I
think are the best ones oh really
yeah I think if you can nail it like I
think the 40 year old virgin is a
perfect title yeah it's really good it's
too good of a title it tells you exactly
what the movie's about yeah really song
Wedding Crashers uh I think is it crazy
do you like nail on the head like yeah
oh if you can get that I know some
people like a little bit more if they're
like what is the deeper meaning well
that's the design yeah well but it's
both it's both they're literally
descending tell me about them tell me
about the title okay it works with
somebody that's what makes it a perfect
title it must be one of my favorite
titles yeah because it doesn't exactly
tell you what it's not like The Descent
to a cave you know but it still is uh
it's a pretty perfect title
I truly do good job Neil do you have a
favorite title
no I think as you said that I was
thinking like is this the greatest
[Laughter]
could be yeah might be just might be I'm
a great when movie fights was around
that would have been a great question
I'm sure he did it at some point what is
the best that was the first thing I ever
saw on TV fights your hosting was I
awesome you were awesome leave it in the
comments what's the best title for any
movie ever yeah do it is descent too
worth watching ladies and gentlemen
thank you so much for being here Roxy
thank you again for being here and
killing it nailing it way to go you
nailed it it was great first thing he
ever did here was a horror movie so it's
great to bring you back here for more oh
no Greg oh no oh no oh no no no oh oh
yeah
what
that's what I thought was happening this
morning all righty well thank you guys
so much for being here and uh we'll see
you all soon peace out reject Nation
foreign